avec 4 millions d'habitants dans sa
grande région la métropole contribue aux
émissions de gaz à effet de serre la
plus grande part c'est le transport la
moitié de la pollution vient de la
densifier les veines lutter quand il est
à marbaix reste une des principales
choses qu'on doit faire on a encore
beaucoup trop d'étalement qui fait qu'il
ya des infrastructures qui sont mis en
place une dépendance à l'auto solo des
distances de plus en plus grands ce
spécialiste des changements climatiques
est du même avis le parc automobile
augmente deux fois plus vite à un taux
deux fois plus rapide que celui de la
population alors c'était c'est
insoutenable on est forcé de prendre des
décisions effectivement qui vont être
impopulaires dont le plan climat de la
ville de montréal on propose de
réfléchir à une zone où seuls les
véhicules non polluants seraient
autorisés qui pourrait ressembler à ce
quadrilatère
il va falloir que collectivement c'est
en soit prêt à avancer à savoir des fois
faire des choix pour atteindre les
cibles de la ville soit une réduction de
55 % des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre d'ici 2030 et la carboneutralité
zéro émission d'ici 2050
je les patients qu'il va falloir
attendre que ça fasse extrêmement mal
pour qu'il se passe quelque chose
j'apprends pas beaucoup ma voiture je
vais pas travailler en voiture je marche
le plus spacieux viol virage aux
voitures électriques ça va super bien
mais elle ne représente pour l'instant
qu environ 2% de tous les véhicules qui
circulent à montréal les meilleurs
alliés pour réduire la pollution les
autobus et métros
montréal est une des villes a au canada
et en amérique du nord qui a le plus
haut taux d'utilisation des transports
collectifs ça nous vraiment ça nous
démarque selon la firme work score parmi
les villes de plus d'un million de
personnes
montréal se classe troisième en amérique
du nord pour la qualité du transport en
commun
l'autre combat ce sont les îlots de
chaleur les quartiers les plus pauvres
de la métropole sont aussi les moins
vert on prévoit planter 500 mille arbres
en dix ans ici mathieu prost radio
canada montréal